[Musique]
avec vous Michel elmidoro et on débute
avec le chiffre du jour 324 324 jours
nous sépare de l'ouverture des Jeux
paralympiques de Paris 2024 et ce lundi
la biillatterterie de l'événement qui se
tient du 28 août au 8 septembre 2024 à
ouvert officiellement depuis ce matin
2,8 millions de billets sont en vente
mais attention cette fois-ci pas de
tirage au sort première arrivée premier
servis chaque acheteur pourra se
procurer jusqu'à 30 billets dans les in
les épreuves de paraéquitation auront
lieu au Château de Versailles le
paracyclisme sur piste se déroulera au
Vélodrome national oui quelquesunes des
images des derniers Mondiaux de
paracyclisme sur piste he qui s'était
déroulé l'année dernière au Vélodrome
national des communes yvlinoises placé
Michel en état de catastrophe naturelle
elles sont au nombre de 5 il s'agit des
communes d'andrésie des loges en Josas
de Saint-Ser l'école de joir
Pontchartrin et de boisimau voisin
reconnu donc en état de catastrophe
naturelle au titre de la sécheresse
survenue entre le printemps et l'été
dernier l'arrêté au Journal officiel a
été publié le 4 octobre depuis cette
date les habitants concernés par des
dégradations de leurs biens ont 30 jours
pour déclarer leur sinistre auprès de
leurs assureurs s lancé du côté de
l'Université de Versailles 50 an Yveline
l'événement c'est les semaines de
sensibilisation à l'alimentation et
l'agriculture durable oui et c'est
jusqu'au 20 octobre au programme
sensibilisation au gaspillage projection
d'un documentaire sur le thème de
l'engagement environnemental ou encore
une un escape game sur les défis du
recyclage depuis le début du mois le cru
propose aussi deux plats végétariens sur
les à tr plat du jour dans les
restaurants universitaires les mardis et
les jeudis et si vous aussi prês de chez
vous comme d'habitude vous êtes témoin
d'une information qui vous fait réagir
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news